voy a hacer un vídeo más sobre la
entropía y tal vez haré más en un futuro
pero pensé que por ahora haría otro
porque realmente quiero clarificar la
idea de la entropía como una variable de
estado una macro una macro variable una
s que significa entropía qué es una es
una macro variable macro estado ok voy a
escribir esto incluso con rojo macro
estado una variable de macro estado y
hablé un poco sobre esto en el vídeo
anterior pero pienso que incluso allí no
fui tan exacto como debía haberlo sido y
la razón por la que quiero decir que es
macro es porque hay una fuerte tentación
a señalar a estados micro específicos y
decir esto tiene más obtiene menos
entropía que esto otro por ejemplo el
clásico y que incluso yo hice en
realidad voy a hacer una línea más
gruesa y grande
así que tenemos esta caja con una con
una pared divisoria ya hemos hecho estos
múltiples veces
y vamos a dibujar esta división aquí muy
bien ven al principio si tenemos un
sistema en donde todas las moléculas
están aquí por tanto este es nuestro
primer escenario ok y nuestro segundo
escenario hemos estudiado ya mucho esto
nos deshacemos de esta pared aquí la
vaporiza moss y calculamos la entropía
déjenme copiar y pegar
ok voy a ponerlas una al lado de la otra
muy bien ahora tengo estas dos cosas la
segunda vez eliminó esta pared voy a
quitar la vamos a quitar esta pared de
aquí y entonces dijimos que una vez que
el sistema alcanza el equilibrio
nuevamente recordemos que estas
variables de estado macro como la
presión el volumen la temperatura la
entropía son solamente definidas una vez
que el sistema está en equilibrio
entonces una vez que el sistema esté en
equilibrio estas partículas son ahora
okay quiero el mismo número de
partículas voy a borrar algunas de estas
y las voy a mover
hoy no esté
déjenme seleccionar estás ok las movemos
ahí ahora tenemos voy a dibujarlo
nuevamente para volverlo a hacer más
uniformemente tenemos 8 partículas voy a
borrar lo que tengo aquí voy a hacer una
distribución más uniforme ok
entonces me deshago una vez que me
deshago de la pared podría tener 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 8 partículas y la razón por la
que hago todo esto es porque hay una
tentación a decir que este estado que
acabo de dibujar jaja este estado que
acabo de dibujar cuando me asegure de
deshacerme de la pared en realidad yo
dibujé un microestado ok esto es es cada
vez que alguien dibuja en realidad
moléculas están dibujando un microestado
de micro estado ahora yo quiero ser muy
claro este micro es el micro estado no
tiene más entropía que éste de hecho los
microestados no tienen entropía la
entropía no tiene sentido lo que se
puede decir es en un sistema y esta vez
voy a voy a dibujar sin partículas y
tengo un recipiente de este tamaño
digamos que contiene cierto volumen
digamos un volumen de 1 su temperatura
es igual a tf1 y tiene
8 partículas esto tiene cierta entropía
asociada y lo que se puede decir es que
si vamos a doblar el tamaño de este
recipiente que hicimos al deshacernos de
la pared ahora de pronto nuestro volumen
es igual a 2 b 1 ajá si decimos que es
el doble de nuestra temperatura aún este
1 y vimos eso en vídeos anteriores
también tenemos 8 moléculas a 1 ok la
entropía de este sistema es más alta así
que ahora la entropía es mayor y quiero
hacer esto muy claro porque ya que lo
dibujamos de esta forma la gente siempre
tiende a dibujar muchas moléculas por
eso confunde el detalle porque cuando
dibujas moléculas estás mostrando un
estado particular por ejemplo este
sistema si lo fuera a medir digamos a
medir por microestados podría tendríamos
una probabilidad infinitesimal de que
tengamos las 8 moléculas de esta forma
digo
quizás se podría esperar a que el
universo vaya y venga y haga lo que
tenga que hacer pero podría ocurrir no
puedes asignar la entropía a este
particular estado lo que puedes hacerles
es asignarle no se le puede asignar a un
sistema a un particular de microestados
por ejemplo el detalle del limpio la
habitación limpia versus en la
habitación sucia no y el punto de aquí
es ver que esta dependencia entre lo
limpio y lo sucio en realidad son
estados del cuarto pero más aún está
realmente no son estados del cuarto
porque cuando un cuarto está limpio o
estático a un nivel macro en realidad es
bueno o que quizás este no es el mejor
ejemplo para lo que quiero decir voy a
cambiar de ejemplo vamos a pensar
ahorita en un montón en una baraja de
cartas que están apiladas de esta forma
o por ejemplo las mismas cartas que
estén todas desarregladas de esta forma
ok que están todas desarregladas esto se
afirma que tiene mayor entropía y quiero
ser claro porque este no es el caso
ok ambos de estos sistemas son macro
estados por ejemplo no es como que estas
cartas estén vibrando alrededor de unos
lados atrás más que las otras no es como
que podamos tomar más configuraciones
que estas cartas cuando hablamos de
entropía estamos tratando de tomar una
variable macro que está describiendo un
nivel micro y las cartas por sí mismas
no están en nivel micro no están
vibrando alrededor continuamente debido
a energía cinética o lo que sea si las
moléculas de las cartas están a este
nivel micro digamos y estas cartas
tienen la misma masa que las de la
baraja y si tienen la misma temperatura
las moléculas en estas cartas pueden
tomar tantos estados como las de la
baraja así que van a tener esencialmente
la misma entropía entropía es una
variable de macro estado o una una
función de macro estado que describe un
sistema así que aquí podría haber estas
cartas como un sistema
y lo que me interesa no es el número de
configuraciones de las cartas mismas las
cartas no son no están vibrando
constantemente entonces en el nivel
atómico el nivel molecular mientras este
estemos lejos del cero absoluto que por
supuesto estamos lejos las moléculas
cambian continuamente así que es casi
imposible medir el estado y debido a que
es imposible medir ese estado como por
ejemplo la entropía podemos pensar en
cuántos estados podemos ubicarnos es
decir por ejemplo la energía interna el
presión la presión el volumen la
temperatura todas estas podemos pensar
las de alguna forma que son atajos para
calcular o para simplificar lo que cada
molécula está haciendo y la entropía no
es la excepción por ejemplo la
temperatura nos habla de la energía
interna que es en promedio cuánta cuánta
desde energía cinética y las presiones
que tanto están chocando el volumen es
en promedio cómo están distribuidas las
moléculas la entropía es también una
variable
macro nos dice cuántos estados puede
tomar un sistema un sistema y muchas
veces se confunde esto que se tiene
mucha tentación a apuntar que un sistema
particular tiene más o menos entropía
que otro ok por ejemplo en este caso no
es el caso el sistema es más en trópico
que este sistema por una razón que es la
que tiene más volumen si tiene la misma
temperatura y más volumen entonces tiene
una mayor entropía las partículas pueden
tomar más posibles escenarios en
cualquier momento dado
de cualquier forma espero que haya sido
útil solo quiero ser muy muy claro
porque muchas veces esto confunde a la
gente esto es una variable de macro
estado para un sistema cuando un sistema
está compuesto por cosas que están
rebotando al azar cada millonésima de
segundo están cambiando sus estados así
que es muy difícil incluso medir sus
micro estados no podemos apuntar a un
microestado y decir a éste tiene más
entropía que otro de cualquier forma nos
vemos